[Music]  they are four and eight on the road  against teams in their own conflicts  with the turbos looking to keep them  witless and Andrew Wiggins did he not  put his jersey under the warlock because  Andrew Wiggins is not out on the floor  get ready to start this game that's Rob  Covington is out there Rosalind Carla to  be towns Tosca person in their village  will we're waiting at Andrew Wiggins and  they're going to set Joshua Kofi to the  floor because drew doesn't have a jersey  and finally back from the trading stamp  comes out in handsy that's that's not  gonna make any highlights shows tonight  answer don't worry about that at least  think it's smile about it  Oh Andrew Wiggins